怎么都短视频 怎么短钱 正好今天直播的时候
很多老婆就问到这个问题
那我就同意总结一下 它是一个完整的系统
首先我们先说问题所在
其实整个大口大的市场就是这样的
我们一定要了解上需求 因为有需求
你的产品 你拍的视频也好
才有人买 才有人看嘛 对不对
那大事两个需求是什么呢
就是我们从小的时候 我们已经习惯了
就是正确的案
我们做一件事情 正确的案子是什么呀 对吧
然后我在方向的对象
就像很多人在直播里面经常问我说
胡德哥 我做这个事情
可以吗
胡德哥 我做我是个保骂 我做什么什么可以吗
我做什么什么可行吗
它其实在寻找一种确定性
就需要有人告诉它 这是第一种
第二种是什么呢 就是很多人 他想做事
但是还怕失败
因为我们能过去的时候 也是亏法经历嘛
很多时候也是这么过来的
包括也是我们上学到环境周家里的环境
就是一旦失败了以后 就会受到钱责
所以我们干什么是害怕失败
所以怎么 如果有一个正确的方法
有个途径告诉我 跟着走
那是最好的
那还有人的话 就是从小的时候特别在乎
别人在见过 别人家的孩子
谁在家孩子 谁在说你
特别在乎别人的
别人眼睛 如果拍个视频 别人看见他妈
很容易到这些问题
那还有人什么呢 就是穿越的问题
我来说这些问题 其实是我们很能到现代为止
没有途破 我们也不能说琴爸
就说没有途破的一个主要原因
当然有人穿越了 知道了 说我要穿越他
穿越了以后 我不怕失败 对吧
我也想 我也想去尝试
但是不知道怎么做
不知道怎么做 我们叫什么叫 习德性无助
这种我想做 但是我不知道该怎么做 这些都是问题
我跟大家讲 这样的人口应该争百分之八十一生
应该争百分之八十一生
而且这是强许秀
为什么 因为我们都想穿钱
我都想穿衣啊 我们都知道穿衣怎么穿钱
但是我还怕失败啊
而且我就叫不害怕失败 我也不知道该怎么做呀
所以我告诉你一个方向
就这一个方向都是可以做的
首先第一个改变人确定性
大家都遇到这个问题的
都不知道怎么解决 您知道怎么解决 因为您有形象
您可以去变成确定性
您就知道了我说的做 这个是OK的
对吧 我就按穿衣 这个是可行吗
您就OK 可行 就是知道这个做吧
我做吧 对不对
这是一种
第二种是什么呢 就是刚才我说呢
我想穿衣我不知道怎么穿衣
我想做我受不知道怎么做
为什么我还怕失败啊
但是如果有一个人他带的做
我在什么看着
我特别喜欢
他带的做过在旁边看着
他失败了
哦 这个可是我不能去
哦 他成功了 他怎么做的
我跟着走 是不是很就是这样的 对吧
所以如果您能做过去做别人想做
但是不敢去做的事
你去做而且分享出来
很多人是愿意看的
那还要的话就是我想做的时候
我不知道问题在哪儿卡在这
地方怎么做 你做的时候
你还能带着我 您还告诉我怎么做
或者我从头到尾你做的能忍眼之后来
那我也愿意看
还有都是好多人刚才我说了
就是特别在国边的地方
如果您能活出自己
你身上有光 您能吸引别人
所以特别如果你听明白我
我在说什么
你就知道这个短片来怎么做了
你也知道该怎么准强的
就是这个特别特别简单的事情
就是去做一些人们都想去做的事情
但是不敢去做的事情
对吧 或者是做什么事情
你给别人提供确定性的事情
都不知道面臨选择的手
都不知道怎么做的手
你就告诉别人
确定性的什么
当然你有这个能力
这个能力是可以吸得的
你这视频就一定是OK的
而且一个更简单的事情刚才我说了
就是去做别人不想做
就是不敢做的事情
但是想做 对吧
比如说
我就想
给你们演示一下
我就通过这段时间
我怎么去做副业的
我怎么
我刚才是这么多段视频的
我怎么去做
这个电商的
我怎么通过
就完成了什么东西
我也是个新手
我跟你们做
那很能说已经要劳手了
对吧
人家这个大牛的演示
谁看你
我跟你说还真不是
你拿我来说
我每天直播的时候
先先告诉你答案吗
就是很多时候
他已经没有通了一些了
这张历害人
就没有通了一些了
我给你举劣的
我就说我每天
平时的时候
就是我只要工作的时候
会把直播打开
工作三十分钟
超过十分钟
我们就回答一些问题
看了最多的问题是什么
就是
活得够我想做什么
可行吗
活得够你看我做这个
我跟大家讲
我真的是特别想
愿意特别想帮大家
但是有的那些问题
问的太极处了
我也真想帮
但是我真控制不了自己的情绪
成功制不了自己的情绪
这个问题太简单了
而且简单到我的
不知道该怎么回答了
而且有些时候
我那个情绪接受不了了
什么意思呢
就是
如果有些时候
他一个人翻过了他的那个
那个战案的时候
他就会建认一个
一个知识现状
就他不认为这个东西是
他也不知道该怎么跟你讲
他没有同理心了
存项目就没有同理心了
你知道吧
所以有些问题
我能回答
不能回答
但是我真是
就是反正就是不太情愿回答
或者是回答的时候
也不
脾气也不是很好
对这种
反而是
刚刚学会的人
他愿意给你回答
而且太有同理心
他知道你卡在哪儿了
他的细节点太远给你讲
因为他本身有成就干什么
所以我跟大家讲
一年纪的学生最好老是
其实是二年纪的同学
那你同学能把一年纪的同学讲的
特别的表
因为很多细节的
他有朋友同理心
投观的几万
所以你千万不要认为
一个赞到一个高手讲了
你不能讲
恰恰不是
人们共云想要的是
比他怪一步的人
所以最好的方法
就刚才我说了
就是你给自己电影方向
就是
人们都想说什么
我去做这个事情
都不敢做
我去做
我全程比我自己跑不了
我就给你们演示
对吧
比如说
我想
我让做
我让装个融下
我也是心事
对吧
我把这个事
我想高一言
高一言的话呢
跟成一个月
一个月的一个分一周一周干什么
比如说
我让高一言
那好
我先大家都说
路下换货
那我就给大家讲
我想
下着我把融下搞明白
我因为我也不会
我们在
所以第一天就完了
你才先装融下吧
我跟你讲
很多人都不知道
东下去那下载
那更不需要
更不知道他怎么还装了
你一天花一天的时间
你倒出早速掉
你自己去尝试
搞明白
中间肯定会到可能的
对吧
然后你去大家讲
第一个问题
融下怎么还装
你高一言
用那些可能
我是怎么做的
阿姨东的
你会发现
还有很多人
多了信息
他也不愿意早醒到
也不知道怎么早速掉
早速到时候会遇到
可能
他看到你这就知道怎么做了
第二天
有了融下之后
对吧
你在有一些游思吧
那你告诉你
怎么装死游思
第三天
你可以装一些游思
那个游思比较好手
我是怎么
把它解决问题的
所以你可以问大家
你说你们想听什么
收集问题
然后
这样
就会很多人去
去关注你
那当天没有学义怎么
不要解决
你告诉大家
我们有些去了
我今天看来还是看在哪了
一个必同值的
而且我告诉你
你没做完
这个时候人民
人们他才会真事
他才真事
然后什么
它叫什么
就是做替吗
对吧
所以替替替替替替替替替替
我想做不敢做
你帮我做
我看着
然后呢
我就可以逼坤
而且一旦你做成了
你会发现你这个前面
对吧
我就可以跟着你一块错
这个时候你会发现
你就会有融价
而且一旦做成了
你可以给边缺分享
是不是这样的
还有
还有一个就是很重要的点
就是我说的我是的就是赚钱
赚钱的话真是别人需要的东西
真是还有一个就是新人了
我对你是不是新人的
结果是看着你长的
看着你长大的
成长性
对养成是博助
对我看着你长大的
我看你从不会到会
真是真实的
而且你那个东西对我真的够用
所以我真的是新人你
所以而且我知道你这个东西对我真的有帮助
这个时候基本上就会买达
所以各位
今天其实之前也有人讲过
装好直播是个人问的
怎么做什么样的思美庭
怎么做人钱
其实特别简单